saturday marks president Trump's first
100 days first okay one guy back there
is happy about it this one's for you
then where's Ben it's already it's been
a hundred days seems like a lot longer
it really does something crazy happens
every day yeah
what do you weigh it's just insane I
don't think it's been six months I know
but it's it's a hundred gone yes yeah
keep moving okay okay I notice
interesting a political analysts say
that we are still in president Trump's
honeymoon phase they said that's the
honeymoon phase yeah which may account
for that feeling that we're being
repeatedly screwed
so feeling it's all night long
[Applause]
this guy is very quick to just press a
nipple you just do that here's that if I
didn't ask you do it anyway now I know
his type
today President Trump is keeping busy
dough today President Trump held
separate phone conversations with the
president of China and the Prime
Minister of Japan yeah
Trump was shocked to learn that those
are two different people like wait a
minute didn't I just talk to you which
one of you is Kim Jong good this
Thursday president Trump will be having
dinner with members of the Supreme Court
they're gonna have dinner yeah
however Mike Pence cannot attend because
his wife won't let him dine with that
temptress Ruth Bader Ginsburg hands off
well Bill O'Reilly of course no longer
on television yeah go Bill O'Reilly well
it's one tall Irishman gone more to go
settle down all right
Bill O'Reilly may be gone from
television but he is launching a
subscription podcast yeah that's right
for just four ninety-five a month you
get to listen to our Riley's trademark
commentary with the added bonus of
wondering if he's masturbating now just
add something to what I think
I think he is yes yes yes he is he
doesn't sound this angry yeah he must be
[Laughter]
alright
today astronaut Peggy Whitson set a
record for the longest time spent in
space by an American astronaut and got a
congratulatory call from President Trump
Peggy Whitson did that yeah when Trump
asked what motivated her to stay in
space so long Woodson answered you I'm
not coming down American Airlines is in
the news American Airlines is under fire
after one of its flight attendants
allegedly yanked a stroller away from a
mother with a baby yeah yeah passengers
were outraged that the attendant took
the stroller and not the baby
[Laughter]
apparently you people like babies all
right let me explain why they didn't
love that way like to remove that joke
from the flight over the weekend
musician Kenny G was on a Delta flight
and he gave a brief performance yeah
very nice passengers are describing the
performance as not brief enough which is
a deal like Kenny G or don't you I bring
them up they're like Oh Kenny G they go
yeah but it wasn't brief enough yeah
you're schizophrenic is what you are and
you like babies
you